[Music]
driving through washington you'll find
the kremlin's message on the dial at
105.5 fm
and we are live from the empire of lies
and we are shacking up the lies in the
empire
that's radio sputnik produced by
russia's state media company from
studios just blocks from the white house
but it's wielding this power but the
power seems to be backfiring
on the united states the russians are
not only winning this thing they're
winning it decisively
as russia's war rages in ukraine sputnik
is selling a very different version of
events one where russia is the victim
this is the first time that it appears
likely that it was the regime in kiev
killing its own citizens who it views as
traitors welcome back to fault lines
critics and the u.s government consider
it pure propaganda
sputnik's hosts claim they're just
questioning the narrative though some
are unapologetically pro-russia part of
what makes sputnik so unusual is that it
has managed to stay on the air as other
russian state broadcasters have either
been banned or ceased broadcasting in
the west
that's because sputnik buys its way onto
the airwaves filings with the u.s
justice department show russia's state
media company spent over half a million
dollars purchasing air time in just the
last six months of 2021. if i felt that
it was all misinformation
we wouldn't be airing it peter chartel
owns kc xl radio near kansas city
missouri he's paid five thousand dollars
per month to air six hours of russian
state programming every day and to say
well you should shut down that
programming
because we don't agree with it
just
is directly opposite of what free speech
is all about the u.s government feels
differently in 2018 it forced sputnik
and the american companies that air it
to register as agents of a foreign
government they must air this disclaimer
on behalf of the federal state unitary
enterprise racial civilian international
information agency moscow russia
russia's war in ukraine prompted the
national association of broadcasters to
go further they've called on stations to
drop all russian programming stations
have so far refused viewers and
listeners who know what they're that
what they're watching
and know that what they're watching is
paid for
can view that content with a certain
degree of skepticism
as the war soldiers on so does sputnik
escaping u.s sanctions and reaching
americans directly
jackson prosko global news washington